mesdames messieurs les militants des
républicains ont été nombreux ils ont
été nombreux à se mobiliser pour
l'élection du nouveau président de notre
famille politique
on nous annonçait une participation de
quelques dizaines de milliers de 50
mille dix et on nous avons eu à peu près
cent mille votes
c'est un succès c'est d'abord un succès
pour notre famille politique c'est aussi
un succès pour la démocratie dans notre
pays car les oublie trop souvent la
démocratie c'est le débat entre la
droite et la gauche depuis qu'il existe
des démocraties
cela s'est passé ainsi et cela
continuera naturellement ainsi en face
de la gauche
modernisé qui est celle de la république
en marche il faut un grand parti de la
droite et du centre
et ce grand parti chez les républicains
les républicains sont bien la première
force militante politique de france
c'est en même temps la première
formation d'opposition s'ouvre
maintenant une nouvelle page
cette page elle est construite sur notre
fonctionnement qui est un fonctionnement
démocratique
je voudrais souligner que les
républicains viennent de choisir en
toute liberté au terme d'une campagne
exemplaire et irréprochable viennent de
choisir leur nouveau président par cent
mille votes
c'est une comparaison que l'on peut
faire et qui mérite quelques attentions
de se souvenir que c'est avec quelques
centaines de militants à main levée qui
a été ratifié la nomination du délégué
général de la république en marche
c'est une nouvelle page qui s'ouvre une
nouvelle page qui s'ouvre après les
défaites grave que nous avons connue au
printemps à l'élection présidentielle
aux élections législatives
après les coups bas les trahisons qui
ont suivi enfin nous pouvons regarder
l'avenir de façon positive
je tiens à remercier tous ceux qui ont
permis cette réussite démocratique
cette désignation cette élection
exemplaire la haute autorité
sa présidente anne levade qui a effectué
avec les membres de la haute autorité
un travail remarquable sur le plan
juridique un travail remarquable sur le
plan technique sur le plan informatique
qui est indiscutablement exemplaire
irréprochable
je veux remercier également gérard
larcher président du sénat qui dès le
début des difficultés de notre famille
politique au printemps mais accompagné
accompagner notre famille politique a
remporté les élections sénatoriales a
lancé avec nous la refondation qui est
un travail qui devra être poursuivie et
qui a participé à la mobilisation de nos
militants pour ce vote
je veux remercier également tous nos
militants qui se sont mobilisés qui sont
allés voter qui ont voté de chez eux sur
leurs moyens informatiques remercier les
cadres de nos fédérations remercier les
permanents du siège qui ont fait un
travail remarquable et bien sûr
remercier et féliciter nos candidats
florence portelli maël de calan qui ont
conduit des campagnes également
exemplaire avec une mobilisation
démocratique qui fait chaud au coeur
je veux bien entendu salué le brillant
succès de laurent wauquiez félicité
laurent wauquiez qui au terme d'une
campagne inlassable de mobilisation il a
fait tout cela malgré les embûches qui
était sur son chemin et il réussit ce
soir a rassemblé sur son nom une
majorité
évidemment importante je sais que
laurent wauquiez rassemblera qu'il
trouvera les moyens de rassembler
notre famille politique de la droite et
du centre je sais qu'il sera le porte
voix de l'opposition mais aussi une
force de proposition je sais car nous en
avons parlé qu'il poursuivra ce travail
de refondation politique est
indispensable pour les républicains
comme pour toute la vie politique
française
je sais aussi et qu'il aura à coeur de
bâtir un projet pour la france
je lui souhaite bonne chance je souhaite
bonne chance aux républicains et je
souhaite aussi ce soir avec des
arguments forts pour cela bonne chance
pour la démocratie des démographies
crasy dans notre pays
[Applaudissements]